when you need a combination of things
but what is beyond doubt is that you
need obviously the military capability
to drive them out of the ground that
they're holding because this whole idea
of a what they call a caliphate or a an
Islamic state is a itself a recruiting
tool for them so you need to drive them
out of their positions and I think
eventually we will achieve that aim but
I think then there is a deeper and
broader question which is really what I
focus a lot of my work on with my
foundation today which is around the
etiology of extremism where I'm afraid
that's got a much wider purchase and
even if you get rid of Isis you've got
1520 other groups waiting to take their
place and this is coming out of a warped
view of religion which we need to tackle
at its root which are in the education
systems in many countries who are
educating young people to a closed mind
of view of the world and this is what we
happen to deal with and that could take
generations to change well it could take
a generation I think the right way to
look at this struggle is that it is a
generational struggle because we have
the problem you know every day what my
foundation does also is it tracks this
across the world so you go down you see
literally listed every major extremists
or terrorists in see and it's in the
Middle East but it's also in Africa it's
in the Far East it's in Central Asia and
of course we know it's in Europe so this
is a global threat it will take a
generation to defeat it but the sooner
we put the right measures in place the
sooner we will get on with doing so what
kind of role can our allies in the
Middle East play Saudi Arabia for
instance is in the middle of attempting
to transform its economy into something
beyond just oil with the Saudi vision
2030 what kind of roles of Saudi Arabia
playing that
and the role of Saudi Arabia is
absolutely essential there are an ally
of ours in this struggle I think what is
coming out of Saudi Arabia at the moment
is really exciting and really important
that development for the country for the
region for the wider world
and you know the good news and sometimes
when you have told me about this people
say okay you know it's so depressing
tell me some good news well the good
news is this that there is a real
possibility of alliance within Islam and
within the Islamic world to fight
against this religious extremism and
intolerance and to fight for the idea of
societies that are tolerant across the
boundaries of faith and culture and
those allies are also there in the
Middle East so yes a lot of the problems
come out of the Middle East but a lot of
the solution lies there also do we have
the right leaders in the u.s. to to
strike those alliances to continue that
dialogue well I think we we do and we
can but in the end it's it's not just
about the person that you have is the
leader it's it's what they're going to
do and the role of America and this of
course is vital because America is the
most powerful country in the world and
we need an America that's strong and
engaged and engaged particularly on this
issue so let's talk about brexit for a
moment because in the upcoming brexit
vote you have a rise of populism in
Europe and of course the United States
distracting government's from
confronting some bigger issues including
Isis if we meld the two together to what
extent is that emotion overtaking the
rational arguments first
staying put well when you look at the
polls you know they're pretty evenly
matched remain orally but my best
instinct about this is that the country
will do the sensible thing and stay in
the European Union because if we were to
leave that would put a level of economic
risk and insecurity into the ordinary
family household that I think most
people would think is a foolish risk to
take so I believe we will stay but I
have to say you know I look at politics
around the world today that's in an
unpredictable state when the president
President of the United States President
Obama spoke in the UK recently it seemed
like he swayed things in the towards the
stay camp perhaps just a little bit
moving the needle a little bit why do
you think that is why did his words have
such an odd because I mean if you're
rational the view of the president of
the most powerful country in the world
in our biggest ally should matter so
when someone like President Obama comes
and you know personally I think it's
important we know his view and the
strength of his view and says look we as
your ally want you to stay because we
want a Britain that's engaged with the
world and I think it does count and
remember you know the European Union is
that the market the largest commercial
market in the world is the biggest
political union we sell half of our
goods into the European market if we get
out of Europe the really crazy thing
about the situation's we will then have
to negotiate step by step our way back
into the single market so you know when
you stack up the arguments as you say I
mean the rational side of the arguments
very clear and you've got to hope
ultimately that whatever the the
emotions are
people take a rational view of the
interests of themselves their families
and also the country so much of the
debate on brexit hang hinges on
immigration looking back at your time as
Prime Minister were you wrong to open
the doors to Eastern Europe without
transitional controls if you could do it
all over again willing to do differently
you know there's a big debate about this
I mean personally I do not feel that the
immigration from Eastern Europe was a
problem for Britain you know I think
those people contribute far more in
taxes than they'd ever taken benefits
they're hardworking people
they're good members of our community
and after all the benefit of having
Eastern Europe in the European Union's
enormous think where we would be today
those Eastern European countries weren't
part of the European Union so you know
in the end incidentally if we want to go
if we voted to leave and then wanted to
go back into the single market free
movement of people would be one of the
things we'd have to have so look you can
go back and to me what we did 10 years
ago because we could have had people
come in it at a slower rate that's true
at that point but all in all I think
Europe has been good for Britain Britain
has been good for Europe and the larger
Europe with Eastern Europe in the
European Union
it is profoundly important for our
security and our prosperity I need to
ask you about the Labour Party do you
think the Labour Party has an
anti-semitism problem well I think it's
important that in the light of recent
events the leadership has set up a an
inquiry into it let's let that take its
course but I mean I know I speak for the
overwhelming majority blamed by the
members when I say
there is absolutely no place the
anti-semitism in our party on the on the
contrary we have always been strong and
powerful campaigners against that type
of prejudice and that sort of poison so
you know it's been a it's been a
difficult time let's say but we'll have
this inquiry take its course and I'm
sure it will come out with some very
strong conclusions on this and finally
just on a lighter note did you make any
wagers on Leicester City foxes
I think everyone's think why couldn't I
see that coming five thousand to one
it's I mean it's a wonderful and
exhilarating thing I mean it's it's a
sort of captivating moment for the
country actually because it's just the
underdog winning who doesn't know
exactly who doesn't love that and it
what it shows you is by the way that the
Premier League in English football is
the most remarkable league in the world